in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Jerry
and Shanae are with us Merry Christmas
Christmas name where you guys from
Saratoga Springs Utah which is near Salt
Lake City very cool
good good welcome good to have you in
Nashville so you're here to do your
debt-free scream in person yes yeah I
love it how much have you paid off it
paid off a hundred and thirty thousand
dollars awesome and how long did that
take about four years making what kind
of money we started at about forty
thousand this year we're looking at
about a hundred thirty thousand goodness
well describe what happened on the
difference in income well we pretty much
worked our butts off and looked for any
way possible to increase our income and
it's kind of funny the more the better
you manage your money the more money you
end up having to manage that's just this
odd thing isn't it's how it works so
your careers have obviously shot up to
the roof yeah what do you guys do for a
living I'm a software developer there we
go and I'm a mortgage loan process there
we go that's how it works so what kind
of debt was the hundred and thirty
thousand dollars we paid off all our
cards a car and the house how are you 29
and 25 hahaha
what's this house worth probably about
two hundred unbelievable you're so weird
we love being weird Dave awesome very
cool four years later you don't have a
payment in the world no how does that
feel feels great it's very freeing to
not have to you know worry about making
that house payment we'll have a lot more
money to play with a lot more money to
give yeah yeah we've worked so hard to
get to this point now we're just so
excited to see what's gonna come next
and what we can do the amount of
investing you can do and the outrageous
generosity you can engage in is going to
be a stipend you're only 20-something
years old
so tell me what happened four years ago
me you're 21 years old when you started
this in 25 so tell me what happened four
years ago tell me about the journey and
what's the story here I pretty much
started with me just flipping through
radio shows on my way home from work and
I kind of heard your show and I thought
it was pretty interesting the
unconventional yet common sense advice
of you know don't buy things you can't
afford I was like you know what he's
probably on to something Shinae was
never really that big into talk radio so
she was a little bit harder of a sell I
kind of had to pitch it to her as like
hey you gotta listen to Dave's response
here on this person who went 200 grand
and a debt to get a degree in German
polka history and any time pretty much
that you would call someone a doofus she
just busts out in two laughs just the
cutest thing so I kind of pitched it as
an entertainment show but then it's like
hey let's stick around for the actual
financial advice Jerry's the smartest
person I know and so when he started
telling me about it I knew it would work
and I just couldn't wait to get started
Wow so how long have y'all been married
six years six years so two years into
your marriage you look up you've got
credit cards car debt house debt and
you're making 40,000 something a year
right yeah and you started this with me
and normal and you start this plan so
the first time you decide okay this is
it we're really doing it and we sit down
and you're sitting there at the kitchen
table and you did the first budget now
Shinae Jerry she seems like she's real
Pleasant she's smiling and she didn't
calm and but was did y'all have like any
really good budget fights you know what
when you're on the same page there
aren't really that many big blowout
fights I mean we had a few disagreements
maybe recently she wants to get a $40
Christmas wreath or a tree skirt and I'm
I'm kind of like well shut up your house
buy the girl a Christmas wreath what's
wrong with you we will get a Christmas
tree when we get home
what are we going to do we've been so
blessed to be able to work together so
well and be consistently on the same
page that we really didn't have any big
blowout fights or anything like that we
just said this is our goal this is what
we have to do to get there let's just do
it and enjoy it yeah we made a goal we
stuck to it and here we are this is
always the end goal is to come here in
person and we just couldn't be happier
to be here my were certainly honored to
have you you are young rockstars without
a doubt and and you are sickeningly
pleasant but yeah it's just it's awesome
you guys are great God bet y'all didn't
fight I mean we're sharing our
hillbillies we just fight so man
congratulations you guys this is
absolutely incredible when you're
sitting there a $200,000 paid for house
it took you four years to do this so how
many people made fun of you
while you're on this track oh I mean
it's always kind of a struggle everybody
wants to go out all the time where you
know why why don't you have a bigger
house or you know get the cup bigger car
that you can afford
but we've I've been in the same car for
thirteen years now
you know we pretty much just stuck to
the budget stuck what do you drive
I Drive a 2003 Hyundai ok
alright and so now now you're making
$130,000 a year and you don't have a
payment in the world you're gonna save
up and buy a better car I'll be a better
car in the future
oh sure so what do you what are you
thinking of what kind of car um I don't
know we haven't even got that or
honestly we're we're just taking it one
step at a time
well you're not a car guy then cuz the
car guy would have already had all this
figured out yeah you're probably looking
at some kind of piece of Apple hardware
of some kind orange I am a big gadget
guy yeah there we go there's one
drawback it's my addiction to gadgets
okay alright good well congratulations
you guys I'm very proud of you it's an
honor to meet you I'm and thank you for
coming all the way to Nashville to do
this it's an incredible thing so and the
cookies are free that's right and you
know you can have that wreath right
there if you want it
I'll get another one that's just that's
great I love it
you guys are awesome alright Jerry and
Shanae Salt Lake City a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars paid off at 25
and 29 years old how did everything in
four years they started out making 40
now they make 130 turns out when you
manage money God gives you more to
manage count it down let's hear a debt
free scream three two one absolutely
awesome man that's fun
well done you guys excellent job you
guys would be so rich so fast and be
able to do so much not only for
yourselves and for your family but for
others
you